mona bonjour les gilet jaune dont il a
répondu présent pour cette nouvelle
journée de mobilisation mais en effet
ils ont répondu présents et ils sont
plusieurs centaines à s'être mobilisés
aujourd'hui devant la gare de l'est un
parcours qui part de cette gare pour que
l et j les jeunes puissent défiler dans
les rues de paris jusque jusque trinité
où il y aura une pause et ensuite cette
manifestation est bien elle se terminera
vers la porte de champerret je vous
propose juste de regarder sur ces images
ici il y à un dispositif de policiers
c'est important un peu moins important
quand même il faut le dire de comparer
aux autres actes d gilet jaune
plusieurs centaines sont ici plusieurs
retraités également nous ont parlé nous
ont expliqué bien que la réforme des
retraites et le recours du gouvernement
49 ans avait en quelque sorte un petit
peu mobilisé elles les troupes néanmoins
ils se sentent toujours incompris et pas
écouté du gouvernement je vous propose
d'ailleurs d'écouter inda bigot qui à
elle organisé cette manifestation
alors moi ce que j'ai pu constater dans
leurs discours
au sein de l'hémicycle quand j'écoute
moi monsieur edouard philippe
l'ensemble est en train de parler de
certaines mesures concernant le système
social etc
les paient les retraites et personnes
handicapées je me dis oui ils nous
écoutent même s'ils ne nous reçoivent
pas mais ils ne font que balancer de la
poudre de perlin pas parfait parce que
dans les faits il n'y a aucune mesure
puisqu'ils n'écoute pas les mesures
émanant du peuple
jusqu'à présent ça fait six mois qu'on
est dehors on n'a pas cessé de demander
des pourparlers avec une délégation du
peuple pour le peuple
ça n'est pas entendue ça n'est pas reçue
ils nous font croire qu'ils nous
écoutent ou qu'ils entendent la rue mais
dans les faits il n'ya rien concrètement
qu'ils continuent leur quartier de
détruire complètement nos institutions
[Musique]
une mobilisation qui a donc débuté à
partir de 13 heures avec vos loyers de
ce cortège qui commence un petit peu a
défilé dans les rues de paris accompagné
et encadré par lé force de leurs
différents profils son orgue à son
présent ici dans ce cortège beaucoup de
retraités
d'ailleurs en tout cas un rassemblement
qui va durer à peu près quelques heures
puisqu'il est censé se terminer aux
alentours de 17 heures cet après-midi au
nez amont dès lors merci pour cette
précision